[Musique]
villageois c'est une bande de jeunes qui
arrivent sur la place d'un village avec
des camions et qui installe des tentes
une sono de la décoration pour faire une
sorte de fête de village itinérante où
il ya un côté festif un peu à l'ancienne
mais aussi on va ramener des services de
la vie de tous les jours donc par
exemple des tests de santé les aides aux
démarches administratives ou encore des
associations locales pour faire revivre
les villages on est présent sur six
départements et notamment la nièvre qui
est notre implémentation principal on
couvre 30 village toute l'année dont on
est très fier ça a changé ma vie
dans le bourg dans les hameaux livry ces
cinq hameaux c'est aussi grâce à ce
modèle économique un peu différent de
faire venir sur un territoire rural des
jeunes ou ici on a une difficulté
justement à attirer et du coup
villageois permet à ces jeunes de
revenir si suis moi sur ce territoire
peut-être pour leur donner l'envié de
s'installer ici
l'idée vraiment plus mandat c'est
l'obtention du label ville et métiers
d'art c'était le musée de la vigne et du
coup on a gardé le musée de la vigne
mais dans la pièce à côté dans une
petite salle d'exposition ici ensuite ça
sera ça dure un atelier pour l'accueil
des artisans d'art
ici on a vu comment la vie elle jaillit
à partir de l'initiative des élus
l'esprit collectif qui lie entre toutes
les institutions et un rôle remarquable
de l'état dans ce territoire et comment
les habitants aujourd'hui avec une
association ses fabuleuses qui en fait
une sorte d' entreprises de l'économie
sociale et solidaire recrée de la vie
ramène des services en allant vers les
gens
[Musique]